Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full video for the boys
Gen V episodes 1 through 3.
They drop the first 3 episodes.
We'll just cover everything in this one
video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references to the main show.
The boys
like a bunch of crossover characters
and obviously a bunch of parodies
of Marvel and DC comic book characters
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
There's eight episodes total
and they will lead up and set up stuff
that will happen. On the Boys Season four.
They've already started to do that
in the first three episodes. but.
Careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episodes yet,
we'll just start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs
WTF moments in all the jokes
and parodies on Marvel and DC characters.
For the most part,
this show is meant to be kind of
like an X-Men show
because good Dawkins is based on the G men
and they're meant to be the Boys
Universe version of the X-Men characters,
like a bunch of kids at Xavier's school
with special powers.
but in the world of the boys universe,
good talking is meant to be a school
that Vought created to basically just mine
through all the compound v babies
to find potential people
they could make more money off of.
they don't really get into this
during the episodes.
But at the school,
they're like two different tracks.
There's like the theater, school track
and then like the crime
fighting school track.
In the crime fighting school.
It's kind of like the 80 or superheroes
that they think they can make
a lot of money off of in
everybody else is relegated
to the theater school who they just train
to find contracts in show business
like TV shows, movies, stuff like that.
but here's the way that Vought
actually makes money off of these compound
vs superheroes.
Why they go through so much trouble
to set them up as these big stars?
Normally when parents have their children
dosed with compound B, Vought basically
sells them on the idea that, oh,
they'll develop these amazing superpowers.
You'll make all kinds of money.
You become rich and famous.
but in exchange for them
offering their children as test subjects
for Vought
which basically uses to refine compound B
and make it even better,
they also sign a contract with Vought
that says that they'll give a portion
of the children's earnings to Vought.
so essentially they're acting
kind of like a superhero management agency
on the side of them
developing all this compound.
V now during the boys season three, Stan
Edgar said that they were trying
to move away from that business line
into the more profitable
pharmaceutical company
where they would sell
the temporary compounds
to the military in the government,
and they make way more money
and they wouldn't
have all this collateral damage
and all the trouble that comes
with trying to deal with
tons of really weird superheroes.
The whole idea is that Stan Edgar
says that superheroes are on the way out
because he feels like they're more trouble
than they're worth.
But the actual title of episode one is God
You with reference to Good Talking
University, the school that was created
to just send through everybody
who they feel like
they can earn money off of.
So the Red River Institute
is like the other side of that
well winds up happening
is that a lot of the kids that
take compound V as babies develop powers
that are totally out of control
or they drive them crazy or they're lame
super powers, the parents don't want them
or they accidentally kill their parents.
board
then basically sends them to the Red River
Institute,
which is like a holding facility
before they send them
to this other facility.
that's where we get to the whole concept
of the woods
that they tease out
that these first three episodes,
like this special facility that they use
to test superpowers underneath the school.
this is a little bit like an evil X-Men
situation, like an evil example.
Your school in Clancy Brown's character.
Brinkerhoff is the person who helped
start the school
with Vought way back in the 1960s.
I guess it would make him kind of
like the evil version of Professor X.
I don't know if he actually has powers,
though.
Before the season came out, they said that
he did, but it sounds like he didn't.
the actual opening scene in episode
one is a parody of the ESPN SportsCenter
with Vought Sports Network
doing their version of an NFL draft day
for all the superheroes
that are trying to get drafted
by Vought to the seven, the other Vought
sponsored superhero teams like Payback.
There are a ton of sponsored teams
like the teenage kids.
They're like the Boys Universe version.
The Teen Titans,
They mentioned that
pretty much all the members of the seven
are alumni of good Dawkins.
We don't see a ton of homelander
in episode one, though.
so I'm not sure
they actually sent him to the school
because they created him
as a test tube baby.
And it was a completely separate situation
from normal compound V babies.
They flashback eight years
show you how Jazz's powers manifested
when she got her period for the first time
in the whole idea
as they developed later in life.
Normally when compound babies devote
their superpowers, it happens really early
They're a couple of weird references
in the first couple of episodes to like
they make a Jake Paul
a Scott Disick reference.
There's even like a PewDiePie YouTube
reference later in the episodes to like
what while they're playing, the girls
mention a superhero called Lord Kelvin.
He's not from the boys comics.
I'm assuming he's just a parody of Human
Torch or Fantastic Four Firestorm from DC,
something like that.
there are a lot of crossover characters
from the main show on this Gen V show,
but a lot of the characters also like
brand new superheroes
that weren't in the original Boys comic.
she accidentally kills her parents
losing control of her powers,
which is how she winds up in the Red River
Institute, kind of like Victoria Neumann,
who was also part of that facility.
they jump back to present day.
And it seems like the worst possible place
to actually dump your kid.
is filled with Vought paraphernalia
for the seven posters,
pictures, all kinds of propaganda
homelander goodluck in posters.
They all aspire to go to Guadalcanal
because basically they explain
the alternative for these kids
is that they get routed to this other test
facility where Vought turns them
basically into glorified pink cushions.
generally, the series is meant to
take place after the events of the boys.
Season three.
There are a lot of references and stuff
that recently happened to the boys
Season three to like one of the kids
says Starlight had just left the seven.
She does that at the very last
episode of Season three.
there are a lot of references
to Homelander's trial
after the events of Season three where
he killed that dude for coming up on Ryan,
zooming in hands on the textbooks
that they had the kids reading there too.
They're all about
how to become superheroes.
Like none of this information
actually seems like useful information
that you would expect
to be taught in schools
like it's all about developing
your branding as a superhero,
which Homelander jokes about a lot,
but really only cares
about the merchandizing
potential around superheroes.
Like they don't actually care that
superheroes do any good or save anybody.
there are couple references to Homelander
in Crimson Encounters in the book,
a lot of Crimson Countess references
at the school later to Notice
that they're all written by Clancy Brown's
Richard Brinkerhoff character,
their evil Professor X,
even though they kind of want
to make him seem like a benevolent figure.
Later in episodes, like the kids
kind of like him, he does seem like
he was behind a lot of this stuff,
so he is pretty shady.
the hoity with Marie's powers
is he's basically like a blood bender
to make an avatar.
The Last Airbender reference.
there are other characters across media
anime that have powers kind of like this
to the way they show her using her powers.
She's not that powerful yet.
Like she hasn't learned
how to use her powers that well yet.
but I think the idea is that potentially
if she could figure out
how her powers work exactly,
she could wind up controlling
way more stuff,
way more people just in general.
but for those who are asking
about power scaling,
like who's more powerful than who,
the whole idea is
that Homelander is still meant
to be the most powerful person
on the planet by far.
So for instance, Victoria Newman,
people wondering could she pop
Homelander said, Could Marie drain
all of Homelander's blood?
For the most part.
The idea is that Victoria
Neuman, for instance,
is not powerful enough
to pop, Homelander said.
Like she could not do that.
so we think the idea, too, is that Marie
could not kill Homelander with her power,
Personally, right now
I think they're headed in the direction
where Ryan winds up being the only person
who's actually strong enough
to kill Homelander
because his powers are based on humor,
like he's homelander's biological child.
One of the kids gets taken to that
Elmira Adult rehabilitation center.
That's like another version
of boss companies that experiment on them
refining the Compound V formula.
Basically just do
whatever they feel like doing with them.
they have a joke about one of the kids
watching X-rated superhero movies,
which they teased with said
Rogan's character
during season three in Crimson Encounters.
Like he was sending for Crimson
Countess, who's also Cam Girling
or like had her own version of a Boys
universe only fans page the real reason
why she winds up
winning that full ride to get Dobkin
is because Vought thinks that her powers
might wind up being profitable enough
for them to earn way more money off of.
Like we'll throw
a little bit of money at you
because we think we're going to make
a ton of money off of you potentially,
the whole idea is that good.
Dawkins is a university
does not meant to make people smarter,
like traditional schools, universities.
is basically meant to train superheroes
that they can make more money off of
they do not care how smart you are.
they have a longer parody of a college
welcome video.
I think they released this online
before the season came out with them
joking about safe spaces
and all that kind of stuff
is basically a bunch of propaganda.
Like Vought
doesn't care about any of that stuff.
they see that Vought created
the college in 1965 that would have been
before the Vietnam War was done.
In the time
Stan Edgar created the Homelander project,
they started experimenting on him,
creating homelander basically.
butt on the boys show
Homelander was born in the early eighties,
so the school predates him by a long time.
probably just one of its early attempts
to earn more money off of superheroes.
So that was Stan Eggers whole thing
when he developed the idea to create Home.
They're like, okay,
we have soldier Boy here.
He's got a little bit of money for us,
but he's way more trouble than he's worth.
I think I can do better
and he creates homelander.
but one of the other projects
they had, one of the other
irons in the fire was this school.
The theater school is named
after Crimson Countess because she loves
performing that Chimps Don't Cry
Video was hilarious.
there's a bunch of stained glass windows
of former current members of the seven.
That's why they have Crimson
Countess and Lamplighter here.
And their crime
fighting school is also named
after Lamplighter,
who we saw during season two,
the funny thing about that is that he
played Iceman in the X-Men movies
and they're kind of doing an X-Men parody
with Cadogan University, end in the Boys
universe, Lamplighter is a parody
of the pyro character, so it's sort of
like him playing the other character
that he was with in the X-Men movies,
they introduce Patrick Schwarzenegger's
character, Luke Reardon, who's called
Golden Boy.
That's a parody of Cyclops
because we're talking about X-Men here.
Like his girlfriend
is a parody of Emma Frost.
but instead of energy blast coming
from his eyes, his power manifests is fire
all over his body.
so he's a little bit more like sunspot.
If you're making more X-Men references,
she enters the school for the first time,
clocks the security guard.
But the joke here is that
the security gate is not to keep dangerous
people out of the school.
It's to keep all the superpowered students
trapped inside the school that they
tried to escape, which we see later,
that's also why the windows don't open.
And you can't break them either.
the R.A.
on her hall is a parody of the Invisible
Woman from Fantastic Four.
Also kind of like the translucent
character reminding you
that he like translucent or also naked.
That's the way their powers work.
Like they can't wear clothes
We find out that Vida's blaming the battle
at the end of season three against Soldier
Boy as an attack by the Russians.
In the comics,
there's a much bigger Russia plot
that Vought has with tons of lower
grade superheroes.
But I think this is meant to be something
completely different
they reference Homelander standing trial
for killing that dude in the finale.
They've released a couple promo videos
for that too, with Ashley
just making funny comments about hashtag
whom free keep him and Ryan
in your thoughts and in your prayers and
be sure to post with hashtag home free.
So he can see your support.
there's no way that
Homelander would actually let himself
be held on trial or be sent to prison.
So obviously it's going to go
in some weird direction.
At the beginning of the boys season four,
they mentioned that everybody thinks that
Queen
maybe is dead, which we know she's not.
she meets her roommate, Emma, calling
herself Little Crickett, who's basically
another parody of Ant-Man and the WASP,
or even like Cassie Lang's character.
I don't know how big her YouTube channel
is or how many subscribers she has,
but she be earning a lot of money
from that already.
that becomes a big thing
with some of the other characters
on the show, too,
like a couple of the other students
have big social media followings
that are trying to earn a ton of money
from.
turns out her gerbil is named
David Caruso.
She's like a movie buff,
and she named him after the Jade movie.
If you haven't seen the Jade movie, it's
actually a pretty deep cut
We find out the schools using the stadium
is sort of like an open air gym
so that spectators can watch people
using their powers.
in they basically have sparring matches,
kind of like injustice
fights from the game.
they start to see this whole Woods
storyline with Golden Boy and his brother,
the nightmare he's talking about in
the woods
is his brother
trying to communicate with him?
I don't know if that means that
his brother also has psychic abilities
or he visited his brother
and they just wiped his mind
they haven't fully explained
his brother's powers
other than he has super strength
and something is wrong with his mind.
But that just might be another wrinkle
in the way his powers work,
and they're just not fully understanding
how his abilities work.
basically
the woods is that secret test facility
that Vought uses underneath the school
to refine people's powers compound.
He basically trying to find ways to make
more money off of their super powers.
golden boy.
Ones of ripping that dude's arms
off, revealing he has a healing factor.
Just like Wolverine and Deadpool.
she meets the Jordan Lee character
who has shapeshifting abilities
and can also give off
blast from her hands.
She also has super strength
depending on which gender she is.
Like when she is a male.
She has super strength, super durability.
But when she's a female,
she can give off those energy blasts.
There are couple of jokes about them
rejecting Marie from the crime
fighting school because she doesn't
have superhero potential,
like she doesn't have a big enough
social media following
because remember,
that's all that really cares about.
They don't actually care about
you stopping any real crime,
be kind of like if Disney were able
to actually create real Avengers
characters, it only used them for
merchandizing purposes.
sand and tries to escape,
but Marie accidentally stops him
without understanding what's going
on, as well as Andre's character,
not realizing that he is
Golden boy's brother.
that a lot of little references
to jokes from the main boys
series like Vought Plus, which is like
their parody version of Disney.
Plus they did a bunch of funny promos
for that
a couple of years ago
when Disney Plus first launched.
Apparently, Zach Braff
is also now canned into the boys universe.
There are a bunch of real life celebrities
that they also mention during this
two break tells Golden boy
that he's supposed
to be bigger than Homelander
and shows him the super suit
they're going to give him.
It actually looks a little bit
kind of like the color scheme
of sentry suit in the Marvel Universe.
But obviously his powers aren't
anything close to centuries.
Homelander is much closer
to being kind of like a version of Sentry.
we meet Chance Perdomo. His character.
His powers are magnetism.
His father has powers like that
to his name polarity.
They're basically magneto parodies
talking about X-Men comics.
Again, they introduce the character
who's kind of like in this weird
three way relationship with Golden Boy.
And now Andre, after his death,
she's meant to be a parody of Emma Frost.
You could also say
she's a parody of Jean Gray.
She seems a little bit darker than Jean
Gray, though, basically blanket
psychic powers.
That's why she wears the gloves,
because kind of like Rogue in the X-Men
comics, the minute
that she physically touches
someone's skin to skin,
she affects their minds.
they're couple of jokes
with the Emma character
hooking up with that random dude
and going super small.
Like, they almost do another termite thing
is joke from the beginning of boys
season three, but they kind of save that
for the end of episode three,
where she kind of does a version of that
like Ant-Man in Avengers
Endgame, going inside Iron Man armor,
messing with his stuff.
she explains the dark twist by her powers.
She has to throw up to go small
and to get bigger, she has to eat things.
So just this weird cycle.
But every time she uses her abilities,
she goes even smaller.
eventually they might wind up
doing some sort of quantum realm
kind of joke, Like eventually Ant-Man goes
so small that he goes into another realm
in the universe of the boys.
Mostly though the consequence
for using your powers in the wrong way,
or using them too much,
or trying to use them for too long
is you basically just wind up exploding
they go out to the club.
But there's an accident where Andre
accidentally almost kills a girl
and they try to blame it on Marie
because Vought thinks
that she has the lowest potential
for superheroes.
Like, No, no, we need to protect
the valuable superheroes.
Golden Boy starts remembering
what actually happened to his brother,
then kills Brinkerhoff, tries to kill
Marie, and then winds up killing himself.
Just going supernova, basically. wall.
This crazy stuff is also going down.
They make a bunch of A-Train,
Turbo Rush jokes.
They had a whole parody video
that they did for it during season three.
there was a quick post-credits scene
at the end of episode one,
basically like a next week
on kind of trailer.
Like this is what's going to happen
in the rest of the Boys series.
But they do it as if Ashley is releasing
like a promo video
in the universe of the Boys.
episode two is called First Day
is In the first day of actual classes.
They have a black noir sign, basically
like a keep out private property
sign as they clean up the damage
we get another cameo scene from Ashley
with the school's board
agreeing on their spin story.
Like, We're
going to blame it all on Golden Boy
and just say he had a psychotic break.
Then at the memorial for everybody to die.
Cate also makes one of the students
yell Jumanji
while hitting himself in the nuts
with the baseball bat
all day, which they pay off the joke later
in the episode, too,
with him, just like walking
with the kid in the background,
still hitting himself
hours and hours later.
there a bunch of jokes about Vought merged
like Vought has versions
of Apple products like speakers AirPods
that they call the pods.
They even give memory of Vought
branded
we meet Andre's father Polaris,
who comes to the publicity shoot
when he says he was younger
had to say Matchbox 20 from a crazy person
at Lollapalooza that would put him around
like the mid to late nineties.
it sounds like his father wants him
to take the mantle of polarity from him,
and it does seem
like he genuinely cares about him,
but is on the board of the school
and knows everything that Vought is doing
is trying to protect his son from that.
Because later when he asked them about,
he's like, No, no, no,
you cannot talk about this.
They will kill you on the spot.
There's a lot of questions
about their relationship
to, like, is he his biological son?
Did he do some with compound B
when he was a baby?
Was born with powers?
I think the whole idea is that
in the universe of the boys,
it's a little bit different in the comics,
But on the TV show,
they want to see that
Ryan is the first superhero
who was born with his superpowers
and like superheroes, can potentially
have babies on the show at least.
but if their children develop compound
these superpowers
is because they gave them the serum
after they were born.
there's a bigger twist
behind this in the comics in the comics
the side effect of compound V is that it
basically makes you sterile
So superheroes aren't supposed to be able
to have children, The comic book
Homelander is meant to be the first person
who actually does sire a biological son.
this this whole running storyline
with Marie sort of drinking the Kool-Aid,
kind of leaning
into all the propaganda,
saying, the lies that they ask her to say
in the interviews,
when they call her the black Starlight,
like, yes, that's meant to be a joke.
But I think the real joke here
is that Starlight eventually expose Vought
in the seven in turn against them.
in it sounds like Marie is going
to wind up doing something similar.
they reveal Adam bought
PJ Byrne's character from the main
show is now leading the theater school.
But it's sort of punishment
for exposing himself to Minka Kelly,
who is also now Khan into the boys
universe.
there are a couple of jokes
about the Dawn of the Seven movie
from last season two in.
Apparently.
He also is looking to hook up
with every single one of his students,
like Mold that clay.
then because Vought
feels like he can profit from
what happened around Golden Boy's death.
Like this whole spin.
They let Marie into the crime
fighting school
because they want to call her
the guardian of good talk
and basically a Guardians of the Galaxy
reference
when Emma is trying to work with the girl
who then later outs her, they're looking
at a bunch of parody movies in universe
like Dawn of the Seven Pocket Romance
basically a bunch of movies about
shrinking in Ant-Man related characters.
Apparently they're all movies
that were made by Termite under Vought
when he was still alive.
they make a Bryan Singer joke
saying that Termite was also connected
to all the shady stuff
that he got up to in real life.
And that's actually true.
Like all the nasty stuff
that you hear about Bryan Singer notice
when she says
they think that Termite died of an ode,
He was actually killed by Homelander
during the boys season three
when he should have been here.
Orgasmed Smashing him with his boot,
which is meant to be a joke on the Loki
Ant-Man book quote from the Avengers movie
They start
learning more about Golden Boy's
brother and what's cover story was that
he died inside the Sage Grove facility.
that's the same special lab
vault was using during season
two to create a more stable version
of the compound formula.
Just testing on all these subjects.
there's another joke about Cate
using her powers
to force a couple of guards
to get it on with the flashlight R.I.P.
to that guard. He's
going to need a lot of surgery after that.
then episode three is titled Think Brink,
which is the title of the fundraiser.
The fourth rose to earn more investors
for the company and for the school.
Like, the whole idea is
they're basically just trying
to trot these superhero kids out,
showing them,
Look how much money
we can actually make off of this.
So please invest in our company,
invest in the school.
they have a flashback to Sage Grove
from three years ago.
Remember,
this is the same lab from season two
to reveal the backstory for what happened
with Golden Boy's brother.
They passed Love Sausage in the hallway.
He also came back during the Hero
Orgasm episode.
We learned that his brother Sam
is just one of those kids
who doesn't learn
to control compound powers.
So he thinks that he's crazy.
But it might be some wrinkle
in the way that his powers work.
He might have some weird mental abilities
to Marie winds up finding
Emma, who's stuck really small
and needs to eat to grow back.
She says that she's been fighting
ants all day because she's grown so small.
Apparently all the versions
of Ant-Man in the boys universe
are not friends to ants
like they are in the actual Marvel movies.
The dean reveals
that she used to have a daughter who died.
Maybe something went wrong with her
compound.
B treatments,
because it sounds like she's worked
for Vought for a long time,
but But it also sounds like
she used to be a clinical psychologist.
And the reason why Vought hired her to
manage the school is because she's so good
at dealing with all these crazy kids
with crazy powers.
but at least in present day,
her real job as Dean, like the true
job, is just raising more money,
not actually helping kids.
they have another joke about the deep
eating is friend Timothy
the Octopus from season three
with Vada Burger, the calamari poppers.
When Jordan's parents come to visit them,
Then Emma winds up using her powers
to break into Sam's holding cell.
Notice they've got a Betsy here with fire
based powers.
They're a bunch of fire based characters
in the boys universe.
but it sounds like they're superheroes
in all these cells.
And Sam said he knows the codes.
So obviously they're trying to tease him,
opening all the doors and everybody
going crazy.
Notice he has a payback poster with Jensen
Ackles Soldier Boy from Season three.
Jensen Ackles is also guest
starring on The Boys generally,
but they didn't say which episode
he appears.
I'm assuming is going to be later
in the season.
Most of the boys characters from
the main show will be on this Genndy show,
Zoom in Enhance.
He's also got some homelander sheets
that actually kind of
seems like a nightmare,
knowing what Homelander is really like.
They're a couple more jokes.
Clowning on the deep and on Clancy Brown's
character with the deep saying that,
well,
this school turn me into the smart person
I am today when reality
he is as dumb as Rox.
Remember,
the school isn't about making people
smarter or teaching them anything
other than how to make more money.
when Emma is talking to Sam, we find out
the Star Wars is also canon to the boys
universe.
And apparently
Sam's favorite movie is Waterworld,
which they tell bunch of jokes about like,
no, it's not just about him
drinking his own pee.
There's a bunch of other stuff
going on in there too.
he almost winds up selling her
on Waterworld being a solid movie,
Then the guards learned that she's there.
She winds up
pulling another version of Athena's
going inside the dude's brain,
killing him.
And then obviously,
the next step is unlocking all the cells
and then escaping the rest of the way.
but no, there's a lot of questions about
what's going to happen
in the rest of the episodes,
like Will Vought continue
to try and spin the story about this crazy
break out, this happening
inside the underground lab right now?
What's going to happen with Emma?
Is she also going to take off
from the school to
For the most part, no matter what happens,
no matter how bad the disaster seems.
VOUGHT Ashley
always has some crazy spin story
to make it seem like it's no big deal.
so like half the school could blow up
in this giant superhero battle in Vought.
We just blame it on the gas
leak. Like, No, no, no.
Just a small explosion.
We're dealing with it now. No big deal.
Just another day For the most part,
the series was pretty solid.
I don't think it's quite as good
as the main show or quite as good as, say,
something like Invincible.
We'll be getting Invincible season
two episodes later this year too.
They also teased them.
I go for like seven seasons,
But if he spotted any of their Easter eggs
or references to anything from Marvel
or DC or anything from the boys main show,
just write it below in the comments.
my full episode for video.
We'll post next week, but it'll be after
my Loki Season two Episode one video.
So the whole idea is that Loki season 2
is starting next week, but
at the time that the boys Gen V is dead,
so I'll just do my June the episodes
after I do my Loki episode videos.
The other big reminder is the Ahsoka
finale is next week.
So there is a lot of stuff happening
next week.
Make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here for my Ahsoka Episode 8
finale trailer video and click here
for that Invincible Season 2 trailer
in for that bonus episode they released.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!